[Music]
at second Nazareth Baptist Church
they're feeling joe biden's political
resurrection and loss has always been at
the heart of his personal story in South
Carolina clearly believes in his power
to rise in American voters of all ages
stood by a firm firewall some assumed
was fragile do you think
african-american voters in other states
will feel as strongly as they did here
in South Carolina I do believe that and
I believe that South Carolina has been
an example in that process and so I
believe seeing what South Carolina
brought forth on yesterday will then
compel a lot of others to go ahead and
support byron in the future I might not
be good coz him and Obama are very close
and he's going down
Obama's Road the same way so I think it
would be good for us do you think he can
beat Donald Trump yes I think he can go
toe-to-toe with him we need somebody
strong like that Joe Biden got more than
a lifeline he got a launch pad declared
this candidacy dead now thanks to all of
you the heart of the Democratic Party
we just wanted we've won big because it
it was a win with a huge margin and with
it
momentum this is all about the ripple
effect into Super Tuesday where 14
states vote his victory here was
emphatic enough that he can claim he's
reordered the race and that he's the
overwhelming favorite amongst black
voters the backbone of the Democratic
Party he's positioning himself as the
best alternative to Bernie Sanders he's
still the front-runner nationally but
with a big loss came a smaller lead you
cannot win more states out there and
tonight we did not win in South Carolina
the next three days will determine
whether this was a one-off for Biden or
the start of a true comeback that
narrative can be a powerful political
force
Adelia Lynch Sky News Columbia South
Carolina